okay pause on the [ __ ] talk on the
[ __ ] tock pause on the [ __ ] it's hard
[Music]
so speaking of [ __ ] [ __ ] talk paw
Paw's just kidding okay so the South
Korean soccer team recently [ __ ] a
[ __ ] Mac no I'm just kidding SKS team
or is it because they had the sex toys
in the out wait what'd they do so they
had like a families game like a match
and they decided to fill up the empty
stadium with 30 sex dolls damn it's
wrong like that is because it's sex
stone what sex tile represents in the
government's like oh I thought it was
because they're like you spend way too
much money on this [ __ ] you should have
just got closed dummies are expensive
dude have you tried to buy one of those
no more expensive than a sex doll which
cost about a hundred thousand oh oh yeah
these things are like three the four
hundred all good financing phenomenal
wait three four hundred dollars at three
thousand so they rented these from this
sex company sections where you compete
whatever so they rented it yeah cuz the
sex dolls are like a hundred grand
Ernie like 20 grand or some [ __ ] well
they've done good job cleaning oh it's
the super legit sex dolls to the add the
more real yeah the ones you can just put
in the dishwasher I'm saying like not
just like a blow-up doll but like the
ones that are made to look really weird
why do that they need more of them they
feel like it was too quiet like too
weird yeah so they wanted to like liven
up the stadium here but it's only 32 in
the stadium so freakin gigantic rolling
though wow this one's holding up such a
hater ass rating zero one you know what
though those their life is rough because
they all have resting [ __ ] --is
that's us fighting in Korean well they
have rusty but but the guys that they
had to [ __ ] it makes him so sad that's
why they have resting [ __ ]
yeah well because they know that they're
about to get a gut to the [ __ ]
forehead really really soon
that's the thing about the surgical
masks by the way is like what the
covering up is not necessarily their
mouths but their mouths going like well
what did that be correct cuz they're
going that's true right
I never thought what a [ __ ] mouth
the cheer'd makes eyes don't match
though don't make eye contact me with
your [ __ ] mouth screenshotted Thank
You Bart
alright well so they are saying that
this team here the soccer club FC Seoul
they will most likely face penalties
because there is like strict rules
against using inappropriate or sexual
advertisements so what ended up
happening here is that they got these
sex dolls from this particular company
but they're claiming that they didn't
know or something
but the reason why it was called out was
because these dolls were wearing like
you could see their [ __ ]
know like headbands I had the sexual
like company because it's rentable right
it's like it's like uber but for sex
dolls yeah so then exactly they're doing
they're [ __ ] advertising with this
kid and while they're cheering the dolls
over and then one of the guys felt
guilty is like oh [ __ ] I know this
company and he's like oh wait this is
bad I know that doll and then looking at
the doll right next to them I'll send an
anonymous letter
I like the life-sized poster but guys -
I did they made an effort yes the sex
doll company ended up saying like well
they were supposed to remove all of
these logos
so it's their fault I try [ __ ] one
before I goes up on stage you would are
you I would try nobody even asked you
about it no I mean before we put them on
like if I was one of the soccer players
the stadium thing yeah but don't you
need the energy for the game but then
what if I like her a lot and I play
harder for her Oh cuz it's like not
girls watching the ass tight man you
don't mean well a lot of these guys are
married off to pretty hot ladies though
too but you know whenever they cheat
they don't always cheat hotter they they
cheat you know the cheat down that's
something different it's like all in the
made is this a dyke soccer team what do
you eat yeah
Oh females I don't know why I was
thinking female the whole time
oh I'll take you female soccer team
sounds like what's wrong with that
well I'm assuming it's a male because
they didn't mention likes no but I get
it cuz you're like there's nobody in a
stance that's why totally hey that was a
good one like at that one you're sexist
believe women or whatever it is well
yeah yeah there we go
yes so the the the club FC soul they
said in a statement that they believe
the figures were ordinary mannequins we
thought would they were just regular
ones that have really soft Katie's in an
open mouth but then they didn't explain
life-sized vagina and hands in circles
yeah [ __ ] mouth art you are good at
it you're very good at it so they didn't
explain the reason why they chose this
particular company which is known for
sex dolls they knew it they would maybe
they got a sponsor [ __ ] you should just
say it throw them under the bus because
they're they're not allowed like out of
the club they what they are gonna be
facing like because it's in clear
violation they're not supposed to be
using sexual advertising is it like
erotic and like we didn't know we were
doing business with
come on called Belka bulgogi [ __ ]
Talcott [ __ ] dogs
I'm Jeong ha se hos what's that one
no bulgogi oh I know I say Oh is how
they say hello hello in Korean
yeah with bulgogi I'm expecting a
lifelike [ __ ] bull hoagies below get
inspired I like that pretty good do you
make kimchi one kimchi cheese a lot of
people are like wait why do they even
have a budget for this [ __ ] they should
have just like that's true saved it for
a party or something maybe that was a
write-off for the party afterwards
because they're like we can't go to the
after party club so what we're gonna do
is we're just gonna like [ __ ] these dogs
yeah they have a perfect amount for the
team which is 30 so like afterwards they
can all celebrate and [ __ ] the girls
that work there groupies tear them
they're gonna [ __ ] the groupie they give
literally past the groupies around
[ __ ] oh gosh if you're out there and
you're like you know what I give up on
my things are hard everyone else got to
figure out but me just know that
somebody [ __ ] ordered sex dolls to
fill a soccer stadium to make it look
like they had crowds okay nobody knows
what the [ __ ] they're doing like if you
can learn anything from they knew what
they were doing
it's she like without the mouth they
just look like regular mannequins well
maybe like a voluptuous what do they
look like underneath maybe that's why
they put the mats
yeah this one looks [ __ ] lifelike bro
bankage super cute and then their backs
are extra straight to make their tits a
little too perky I like that I'm onto
them it's kind of like we went to
Michael Jackson in Vegas and he was too
close to us and he didn't look Michael
but then that gets far away he would
look way more like mine yeah he didn't
look he moved like Michael though you do
there was this one thick
sex doll that was going around and
everyone was like if this is the future
of sex dolls then girls are in big
trouble
no way it was our [ __ ]
[ __ ] comparable I don't man if you
put your digging of things though I've
tried I think what is missing is you
know what the reverse feels like and
it's not the same the warmth the warmth
is the is what they're missing
and the kegels they might not have the
Kegel technology you're [ __ ]
completing my sentences the time came
when pornhub send me that fake but
there's um you were sponsored by pornhub
no not was a sponsor but like their
friend a send me this the the the it's
called the twerking but you hit a little
remote it's [ __ ] twerks
it's literally just a but you know with
holes it does like a little white but is
a brown but it is a fair complexion
peach but but yeah it's a peachy but and
the jus bonus and here's the thing I had
to of course but why would have you what
did she just say she she like she was
like you had sex with it and I was like
well yeah you didn't have sex you [ __ ]
it that's different I made love to a
baby yeah I made sweet sweet love to it
the difference and whoa okay here's the
here's the funny [ __ ] is like when when
I tried it out I like [ __ ] I was like
senator like I was like chip out like I
said it like video of it
I'm gonna get it yeah just that you know
just to show this is your future girl
yeah but when you talk about the warmth
that [ __ ] has a you're warming on the
inside no we're warming and like it
vibrates they're getting lucky vibrates
on the inside better learn to cook gl so
I always giving around there's nothing
like literally I was in that [ __ ] for
like ten seconds are like oh [ __ ] I'm
done
really you busted that fast yes dog and
I didn't have to move I was in it I was
like oh he was moving on you it was like
it didn't even meet because it vibrates
and it's warm on the inside we talk back
at all what is this
yeah calm again it's like yeah you
little [ __ ] and I'll say all guys this
is hot no where's the butt now honestly
I don't know where it is you don't need
it anymore
do you got rid of it like you know she
might have could you go like this but
why don't you get such an intimate
experience with it how do you not know
where it is yeah you know what it just
it I put it in an uber and I send it
away I think it's nice to the coyote
came over and he's like Steve's not
gonna need this anymore he's married
it's stapled to the wolf so it's like
the wolf and the wolf was it weird cuz
it's not like a full-on like I don't
know no it's not weird because you know
it's like simple to only you understood
man all right [ __ ] couches and
sandwiches yeah I've never [ __ ] a safe
house I bought the couch present yeah a
guy will [ __ ] a hand yeah if it's a soft
and it's [ __ ] I mean like a [ __ ] fake
hand a guy will [ __ ] a guy and say he's
not gay
I read this one story guy ended up
[ __ ] like 300 pairs of sandals or
something you sold them and like what
kind of sandals 10th class yeah like
time songs yeah like like any kind like
even like the slip the slip what what
what exactly he does not a [ __ ] an old
silly I mean do you put it on the the
thong part or comment on the tongue come
on you already gave it away bro cuz
there's the dirty dirty dirty plug that
side now if you buy a friend I'm sure
that they're probably buying it to get
the foot residue off
26 lip gloss why did that gross be up
with anything else me to be stolen oh
you only went for small ones then right
how did you know that takes a pervert to
know a pervert okay that's how you catch
a criminal
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]